president joe biden signed the 1.9
trillion dollar american rescue plan
into law last week
and democrats celebrated the package as
one of the most consequential
anti-poverty efforts in recent history
the plan includes 1400 stimulus checks
to americans
funding for vaccine distribution and 300
in enhanced unemployment benefits
through august
so who can expect to benefit from this
bill
a huge percentage of americans will get
this round of stimulus checks
those americans who make up to 75
000 a year as individuals will get them
heads of household who make up to 112
and a half thousand dollars per year
will get them
and joint filers married couples earning
up to
thousand dollars a year will get the
full fourteen hundred dollars
and then filers with dependents either
children or
adults will also get fourteen hundred
dollar checks for each of those
dependents
the new stimulus package also includes a
major but temporary expansion of the
child tax credit and what that tax
credit will do is it will send
eligible families again based on income
three thousand dollars for every child
between the ages of six and seventeen
and thirty six hundred dollars for every
child under the age of six
that's a huge boost from what the tax
credit normally gives and the other
difference is that some of that money
will come
in advance of next year's taxes experts
are saying that that credit is expected
to boost
4.1 million children over the poverty
line
during the year that it's active and 83
million children
live in households that will benefit
from the expanded credit
small businesses are also getting more
help in this bill the bill will give
another 7.25 billion dollars to the
paycheck protection program which is
that really popular
federal loan program for overhead and
payroll costs to help the smallest
businesses stay afloat during the crisis
it doesn't extend the ppp although
lawmakers are
kind of expected to do that in the next
weeks and months
and there's also billions more for other
grants and loan programs for small
businesses
due to the massive relief package and
rapid pace of vaccinations
the organization for economic
cooperation and development
said it now expects the u.s economy to
recover twice as fast as previously
thought
all this comes at a cost however
unprecedented spending during the
pandemic
lifted the federal deficit to a record
3.2 trillion dollars last year
and this fiscal year's budget gap is
expected to grow more quickly
fueling concerns on wall street that
rapid inflation could hurt stocks once
the economic recovery kicks into
overdrive
federal reserve chair jerome powell has
said while there may be price spikes in
the short term
in the long term inflation won't be an
issue
but this might not be the only big
spending the biden administration is
targeting this year
it is expected that congress will pass
another big spending bill in the coming
months
president biden kind of has divided his
priorities into
rescue and recovery so the
the 1.9 trillion dollar bill that just
passed was the rescue
half of that equation and the recovery
half
will be the enormous infrastructure
jobs clean energy bill that you know
democrats are already
pivoting towards i think experts are
expecting that bill to come in at at
least two trillion dollars so it will be
just as big if not bigger than the
current stimulus
that just passed it will be a while it
will be months i think before we see
any more spending especially given all
those concerns about debt and inflation
you know adding another 2 trillion in
spending
on top of the 1.9 trillion they just
authorized on top of the five
uh spending bills they did in 2020 it's
it's not going to be an easy argument
[Music]
you